COMMITTEE MEETING TO GET TO
ORDER WE HAVE TWO BILLS BEFORE
US WILL HAVE TWO WITNESSES PER
SIDE LIMITED TO THREE MINUTES
EACH. FIRST BILL IS AB FOR
FOURTEEN BY MR BONTA. WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM SO WILL BE
STARTING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
THINGS LIKE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. YOUR WELL THANK YOU.
THANKS VERY GREAT THANK YOU HEY
I DON'T KNOW. CARE. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING ALL NEIGHBORS THAT
WERE NOT NOR NORMAL SPACE IS A
LOT OF BUTTONS APPEARS. ONE OF
THEM'S A COLORADO FROM THERE
NEVER MIND. INCLUDED A STATE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIANS AND PREVENTS
FURTHER DESTABILIZATION OF THE
INSURANCE MARKET A. B. FOUR ONE
FOUR WOULD ENSURE THAT THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS DATA.
TO INFORM THE LEGISLATURE
REGARDING THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE INCLUDING THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS PAYING THE PENALTY
THE TOTAL STATE WIDE PENALTY
AMOUNT IMPOSED ON THE NUMBER OF
EXEMPTIONS APPLY TO AMONG OTHER
INFORMATION. THE BILL HAS NO
OFF NO OPPOSITION IT IS
ACTUALLY A REPORTING BELL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I HAVE WITH ME HERE TODAY
BETH CAPELLA HEALTH ACCESS IN
SUPPORT. BETH BELL ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA HERE
IN PORT OF THIS MEASURE.
YESTERDAY THE CENSUS BUREAU
REPORTED THAT THE NUMBER OF
UNINSURED AMERICANS HAS
INCREASED FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF THE
AFFORDABLE IMPLEMENTATION THE
AFFORDABLE CHARACTER VERY
PLEASED TO SAY THAT THAT DID
NOT HAPPEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HOPE THAT WITH THE
ACTIONS THIS LEGISLATURE TOOK
THIS SPRING. TO IMPROVE
AFFORDABILITY AND ADD
ADDITIONAL SUBSIDIES AND
COVERED CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
IMPOSING THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
THAT WE'LL WILL IN FACT SEE.
FEWER CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
INSURANCE. THIS BILL. THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY THAT
WE DIDN'T CALIFORNIA'S SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT THAN THE FEDERAL ONE
BECAUSE OUR TAX STRUCTURE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT SO IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE REPORTING
INFORMATION THE DAY BEFORE ONE
FOR WILL PROVIDE. TO ALL OF US
AS WE GO FORWARD TO MONITOR THE
IMPACTS. PRETTY GOOD OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. KAREN
LAYING ON THE OF MARYLAND AND
BRAID AND THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
SONORA BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS ARE COMMISSION
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE WE WILL
WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE A QUORUM
MISTER BONTA SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO. AND WE ARE
WAITING FOR OUR OTHER AUTHOR.
SO WE WILL. WE WILL DO THAT
WE'LL JUST WAIT FOR OTHER
AUTHOR
. BUT. STARTED OUT THERE
THAT YOU KNOW WHERE TO GO. AND
I USED TO STILL GO PRETTY THAT.
THEY DIDN'T DO IT FOR LIKE FIVE
AND EASY. THAT'S ALRIGHT. GONNA
BE ONE OF THOSE THINGS. WHAT
TIME UHHUH
. WE HAVE YOUR BODY
BECAUSE THAT YEAH BUT THE MORE
THE BETTER. MORE STUFF. YEAH I
CAN
. YEAH. WE SHOULD MAKE UP OR
SOMETHING. MIDDLE A. I NEVER
EXPECTED TO BE ON THE LEFT. BUT
WE WELCOME YOU. ONLY HE'S YOUR
FRIEND YEAH. YEAH NOW I DON'T
KNOW. OKAY COMPROMISE ON YOU
CAN GET ONE. AREA THAT WOULD
.
MA'AM SECRETARY WE NOW HAVE A
QUORUM BEFORE MISTER NAZARIAN
PRESENTS AS A I'M SORRY TOO
MANY BUTTONS WE NOW QUORUM
AMEND SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AND THEN WE'LL HAVE MISTER
NAZARIAN PERCENT HIS BILL WHAT.
YOU'RE MAYES HERE AGUIAR-CURRY.
BIGELOW YEAH BONTA BURKE
CARILLO. FLORA. LIMóN MCCARTY
NAZARIAN PRESENT. RAMOS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON.
OKAY. OKAY MISTER IS ERIN YOU
HAVE AB SEVEN FIFTEEN. MISTER
CHAIR SINCE I MADE THE
COMMITTEE WAIT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO TAKE A VOTE ON THE OTHER
BILL. FIRST WILL MAKE THE
COMMITTEE WAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK
AB SEVEN ONE FIVE WOULD SIMPLY
EXTEND THE CALIFORNIA
PARKINSON'S DISEASE REGISTRY
SUNSET FROM JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE AYE
VOTE AND I HAVE WITH ME. MATES
ALL OF REPRESENTING THE MICHAEL
J. FOX FOUNDATION FOR
PARKINSON'S RESEARCH. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BEING A CHECK ON THIS ISSUE AS
PRIVATE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. A CAROLING
ABOVE OF MARYLAND AND RATE IN
THE CITY KIND OF SOME DISCOUNTS
PART. ANYONE ELSE THIRTY ONE IN
OPPOSITION. SEE A NUMBER BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANYONE. A
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
MAYES A SECOND BY MISTER
BIGELOW MOTION IS CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR I JUST LIKE TO
THINK. A GOOD COLLEAGUE DOCTOR
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA FOR A
PARTNERING UP WITH ME ON THIS
BILL AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. IS CONCURRENT OF
THEM AND THE AND THE MOTION IS
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS.
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES MAYES AYE
ANGER CURRY. HELLO HELLO I
BONTA BONTA AYE BURKE. YOU
CARILLO AYE FLORA. LIMóN
MCCARTY NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN
AYE RAMOS. JUST AS THERE IS
REAL. NO SO LIZ AREA. HI REBELS
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ ICE
SANTIAGO THE ROOKIE MISTAKES
SANTIAGO AYE AND WALDRON. BURKE
BURKE I. TEN ZERO IT WAS THERE
IN YOUR BILL IS OUT AT TEN TEN
ZERO THANK YOU FOR FOURTEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE MOTION
ON AB FOR FOURTEEN BY MR MAYES
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO MOTION
IS CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENT
SPENT A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES. AYE MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
BIGELOW. A LOT BIGELOW AYE
BONTA AYE BONTA AYE BURKE BURKE
I CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA.
RAMON MCCARTY NAZARIAN NAZARIAN
AYE RAMOS. PROMISE NOT VOTING.
THAT'S CORRECT. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
I WALDRON WALDRON AYE. ELEVEN
ZERO THE BILL HAS ELEVEN THAT
THOSE OUT CAN YOU SO IT'S OPEN
THE ROLE ON A. B. SEVEN FIFTEEN
AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I. FLORA LOW MOAN
MCCARTY WALDRON WALDRON AYE
TWELVE ZERO THAT'S- TWELVE ZERO
WE WILL WILL LEAVE THE ROLL UP
IN FOR A COUPLE MORE MINUTES
AND BUT THAT CAME. THAT
ESSENTIALLY CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS. THANK YOU. THE
. THANK
MISTER FLORA WILL WILL BUT.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AB HAVE MEANT
SECRETARY OPEN THE ROLL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON AB FOR
FOURTEEN. FLORA FLORA HI Là
MON MCCARTY. SO THAT IS TWELVE
ZERO ZERO AND THEY'LL HAVE WE
WILL HAVE A MASSACRE OPEN THE
ROLE ON A. B. SEVEN FIFTEEN IS
AREA FLORA. FLORA AYE LOW MOAN
MCCARTY. THIS THIRTEEN ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT FOR.
ASK A QUESTION. WITH THE
PERMISSION OF
. NO THAT'S FINE
THANK YOU THAT SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS EIGHTY FOUR FOURTEEN
LIMóN. MON I MCCARTY. THE NEXT
THING AND WE FROM THAT
RESOURCES. THE THIRTEEN THAT'S
THIRTEEN ZERO AND NOW PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS A. B. SEVEN FIFTEEN
LEMOND. LIMóN AYE MCCARTY.
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN SIR THANK YOU
MISTER. OKAY AND TO ME HE THANK
YOU RIGHT NOW. JUST. WE WILL BE
GO AHEAD IT WILL GO AND CLOSE
THE HEARING OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAVE. YEAH YEAH. YEAH
THANK YOU